hello I'm Donna Pearman from walking
distance of America I'm going to talk
about Wolfram language platform for
blockchain smart contracts and first
time what I'm going to show you right
now is what we have been developed for
the last month or this year actually it
is a platform for not only blockchains
but also for developments smart
contracts and also it will be useful for
connecting blockchains as well so
everyone knows what a blockchain is what
I found is that yes most of the time
people talk about block chains but they
don't really know what block chains are
used for or how they work how do we see
it is is like it's the digital evolution
of the accounting books and registers
that's I think probably the most
accurate term so it will probably be
very important in the future but not for
everything like the hype it has today
but let's see so the outline for this
presentation is we're going to show an
architecture for transactions and smart
contracts how to do transaction and
smart contracts in three easy steps
that is creating signing and similar
transaction sec is that cross-chaining
what does that mean
token analysis as well and finally what
we're trying to do right now is
integrating all this with Wolfram Alpha
okay so this is too big
this is better yeah so okay this is a
simplified version of our architecture
right now so how does it work
everyone that has success to a world
from Colonel will be able to access all
the blockchain functions and used and
build transactions and smart contracts
so once you have a world from Colonel
all in your computer or in the cloud or
wherever you use your functions that go
through this API server and they are
then sent to our nodes will have notes
for right now for bit corny theorem and
we have our own world from experimental
blockchain which is based on multi chain
and then when they're ever there's a
smart contract did this is harvested by
harvested by a computer nodes and these
smart contracts are stored in a strand
storage which can be I P FS which is the
for those of you who haven't heard of
this is the interplanetary file system
very important name in the future we
have as free as well of course a cloud
and Dropbox as one asuras we will come
we'll revisit this after a few slides so
transactions let's create a transaction
how do you create a transaction let's
let's make sure we're on the test net so
that we don't spend real money okay we
need an address and a private key to
sign that so these are requirements so
let's get information about a certain
address using one of the new functions
which is blockchain address data what do
we need this for we need to see okay if
we have enough balance do something and
we also need this transaction account
over here because that's it's something
required it is one of the double checks
that the blockchain uses for avoiding
double spending okay
then let's check on the using blockchain
data we can check on the gas prices the
gas is something that we it's a fee that
we pay to the miners so that the
contract
it's mined and included in the
blockchain so we can see if that the
last in the last block the highest gas
price was 15
let's use that so that we can make sure
that it is indeed mine and we have
everything we need right now so this is
that so let's build our blockchain
transaction using those using our the
transaction count the address the gas
price and the amount we want to to send
over to another to these destination
address which is you know a test address
as well and it's a small number it's a
good quadrillion way which is nearly
nothing because one meter right now is
10 to the 18th ways so it's a very very
small number actually so we build this
subject and has everything we need for
the transaction one which we have this
object we want to sign it we use our
private key for that so the sign state
here has changed true and then we submit
it to our node okay as CCS that we build
a transaction we sign it and we send it
to your note that's as easy as that so
we want to check if they're okay if the
the transaction we sent has been mined
if we had done this like very fast we
probably get this message here which is
pending to mine it takes about 10
seconds more or less to get mine right
now in the theorem blockchain so it has
already been mined okay and then we can
check if indeed there has been any
transfer this is this was her original
account with the original balance that
we had and let's see what we have right
now so yeah indeed we have spent a bit
less than a dollar transfer to that and
the transaction cam has has has has
increased so when v has we have just
created a very simple transaction
for transferring ether or way in this
case from one account to another in
aetherium this this this very simple
process is the same for Bitcoin right
now we have the gravity for both of the
drug chains so what about smart
contracts smart contracts are
transactions with conditions that's it
so it's a transaction with if 10
conditions that's what we call it
problems because that's what they are so
we have to add another step to this
which is creating the smart contract
itself that has a little more
complication okay so let's try to okay
let's do a very simple script a very
simple contract that checks for the
wearer of a beautiful city which is
where we live and what we'll do is work
we're going to store this world from
script into an external storage we'll
see we'll see be a wipe later on ok so
we're going to store it in the in the IP
FS and now we're going to create our
smart controller object here ok so this
seems easy and this is busy but it is
not what this function is doing right
here is the language used in aetherium
for doing smart contract is solidity as
probably you know so what we're doing is
we're giving all the template in
solidity and in one of the variables
we're adding the address of where the
smart contract is going to be stored in
external storage so it is it is included
as a payload inside a solidity contract
we're planning to do that there are
languages that they're used for for
smart contracts as well so we're going
to add all the templates for them as
well so this is natural contract made in
solidity including a word from script
inside it that can be run so again we
need a transaction count and once again
the same the same case as before once we
have build or smart contract we do the
same steps as before we'll build a
transaction we sign it
and we submit it so again three easy
steps
the only difference right now is that we
have built a smart contract and included
that smart contract inside our
transaction in the other case we didn't
need that but that's the same thing it's
as easy as that so there's a ton of
things going behind scenes but for for
the user it's as easy as that so let's
check is if the transaction has been
mined it has already been mined and what
we can do now is try and check if the
smart contract has been executed if I do
this right now I probably get a false
and explain why and I'll get back to
here okay so let me get back to the
architecture first so what is happening
here is that okay we're sending the in
the first case for just a transaction
what we do is in a transaction via our
API server and into the nodes and there
it is mined and then it's distributed
through the nodes throughout the world
in the case of a smart contract in the
US in this case it's a bit different
what happens is that we store a smart
contract this war from script first in
one of these storage providers here then
we send the transaction in the same way
of this for but once it gets mind and
into the nodes what happens is the word
from computes nodes would harvest every
block to check for transactions that are
including a word from script to be
executed so once that it's fine okay we
have here the address of our whorfin
script it searches for it in one of the
search providers and executed execute
sit and then updates the state variable
of the contract in the node and it
stores there is a source result again in
a certain storage so it can be retrieved
so that's probably now it makes more
sense
the architecture so let's see that takes
a couple of minutes so probably already
done has happened you has been harvested
and we can use blockchain contract value
now for that let's see true okay so what
this means is that the status of the the
contract has been updated to execute it
so in the husband so let's let's see
what happens let's see what let's
download the result from the thermal
storage let's get the address where it
has been stored first this is the
address where it has been stored we can
get the object here and we can get the
result and this is the result so right
now it's Saints in degrees Celsius which
is a very nice weather and that is how
our platform for smart contracts works
what about cross-chaining I'm not sure
if you've heard about cross training the
problem right now with block chains is
that there was supposed to be one
blockchain for everything and then
hasn't happened of her so we're having
more and more block chains and more and
more specific kind of block chains for
different things and now the problem is
how do we communicate between these
block chains so right now the approaches
mostly for trying to exchange
cryptocurrency which is like the imaan
exchange we're going a bit further than
that
two approaches exist right now one is to
create a block chain of block chains
these two approaches are not the ones
who are doing this is what it sees right
now so one is creating like a big block
chain and you have sub block chains that
connect to this higher block chain okay
the other is include okay
including a piece of code in a certain
block chain to make it compatible with
others what we're proposing is with a
world from plank for approaching
preferring something different is just
include the block chains in our
ecosystem in a symbolic way and then
they can easily interact with each other
so let me give you an example for
example from what you have seen
I can easily do a war from script okay
that gets executed at the get stored
inside the theorem it gets executed by
our by our platform and then we can with
the same script say okay now update this
script a script as true in in the
theorem blockchain but pay in Bitcoin
but go to on our blockchain so with our
code we can easily go from one
blockchain to the other without anything
including conics extra code or doing
unblock changes on it the thing is in
including all the blockchain since our
system so that they can interact with
easy code that's our approach for
cross-chain so what else do we have we
have we have tokens now we need to make
new to make sure we are in theorem as
well in the main it what can we do with
tokens we can maybe get information from
one of them that a crypto kiddies which
I think probably everyone knows we could
retrieve the top holders of that kind of
that token we could get the latest
transfers say let's let's get the latest
ten transfers of it we could get all the
tokens of a specific standards there are
two main standards right now which are a
year C 20 are new year c7 21 there are
many others but these are the main ones
and we can get all of them if you want
to we can also get all the transfers
done between a certain number of blocks
that is between in these thousand blocks
how many transfers have included crypto
kiddies inside them or check for a
transfer for a transfers mean mate in a
certain time interval that is in this
case for this case in ours ten at ten pm
how many transfers involving crypto
kiddies have we had and finally we can
get for example for a holder for a
holler RS let's say I want to
get all the information about all the
tokens that a certain holder has in a
certain standard something like this and
many many other things of course this is
only some examples that were forward
King Garon of course a ton of analysis
can be done from from these cases so
finally what we always do is we
integrate all our products as well so of
course we're gonna work from alpha 2 to
work with this as well so what we have
right now which is experimental still it
was something like ok we can get
information from me from aetherium from
all the room functions actually we can
let check for example first the first
big Bitcoin block this is not the
Genesis block which is a proxy oh we can
get a few rooms last block with all the
transactions including and so on this
will be clickable of course and you can
check on each of them you can get
bitcoins laters hash or when was a
theorem block 15 mined for example or
even something more complex like you can
put a transaction inside and you'll get
information from it hopefully yeah yes
this is experimental so this is why the
syntax is so terrible so it's not easy
getting these two to work so yeah you
can get it for a certain transaction all
information about it just by asking
Wolfram Alpha all the things were player
we're including which didn't make it so
I'm just putting some screenshots years
for information about specific addresses
there are still anonymous but if you
know who they are you can track
everything that they're doing or the
transactions and of course finally
cryptokey this as well or any kind of
for a token you can just ask for it in
what form often you get a ton of
information about that is coming very
soon and I think that's it I just want
to take a minute to mention all the
great team I've been working with I
couldn't be so so much proud to be
working with these people who have
dedicated a ton of time doing this and I
think that's it
thank you very much
[Applause]